all right guys so I'm finally gonna
break down and reveal the secret of the
universe or at least the keto universe
okay so what is the biggest secret of
the keto universe well recently I was
reading this this book in my spare time
called insulin resistance this is a
textbook okay all the research on
insulin resistance fascinating read I
agree with like most of it but there's a
couple points I don't know cover that in
a minute but I'm reading this and all of
a sudden was like it hit me like a ton
of bricks I go wow
most health problems most common health
problems diseases and symptoms are
directly caused by insulin resistance
yet we are treating every single one of
these conditions with a separate drug as
if they are some separate problem and
disease I mean check this out insulin
resistance directly causes metabolic
syndrome high blood pressure high
cholesterol triglycerides belly fat a
fatty liver diabetes okay and having
diabetes causes kidney damage and kidney
failure eventually peripheral neuropathy
all sorts of neurological problems
including problems with dimension the
brain heart problems eye problems
cataracts glaucoma retinopathy all sorts
of problems with the eye and the number
the heart we have clotting occurs
because of this that's what leads to
strokes okay plaquing arrhythmias atrial
fib high cholesterol high triglycerides
the type of cholesterol that sticky that
forms a plaque and high blood pressure
and then we have all the inflammatory
conditions of your joints arthritis
bursitis tendinitis rheumatoid osteo
autoimmune conditions
it's the inflammation that causes the
damage and then we have inflammation
inside the artery which then leads to
the plaquing we have inflammation that
occurs in the digestive tract crohn's
diverticulitis irritable bowel syndrome
inflammation that
causes fibrosis or scarring or cirrhosis
in your liver but then we have all the
problems in the brain Alzheimer's
dementia Parkinson's seizures cognitive
issues like brain fog forgetfulness lack
of focus lack of concentration and then
we have PCOS which is polycystic ovarian
syndrome which is high level of
androgens in a female body normally
females should not have high levels of
androgen where does that create facial
hair body hair loss of hair on your head
deeper voice belly fat and the list goes
on and on but in a male body insulin
resistance will decrease testosterone
okay and increase estrogen so we have
this opposite effect where insulin
resistance in a female body causes high
in regions and Annamayya body will
decrease androgens and then there's a
whole list of additional side effects
from this alone okay and when we have
insulin resistance we're usually a
pre-diabetic where we have high levels
of sugar and yes cancer lives on sugar
and not to mention OBC okay insulin
resistance is a primary driver of
obesity why because the hormone insulin
is the main fat storage hormone now what
is insulin resistance basically your
cells are rejecting insulin okay they're
no longer absorbing insulin anymore what
causes this chronic exposure to insulin
now if we take it back a little bit
further what would cause high levels of
insulin is basically high carbohydrate
diets chronic eating like infrequent
eating as in eating six times a day with
all the snacks and everything will cause
this and cortisol will increase the
production of insulin because with
cortisol which is a stress hormone it
actually breaks down protein and it
stimulates insulin and a lot of the
damage from high levels of cortisol is
really high levels of insulin so high
cortisol eventually causes insulin
resistance itself now if we look at
insulin like a key okay which has a
function
of allowing fuel to enter the cell to
regulate blood sugars it's a master
whole-body glucose control okay
and it also controls amino acid
absorption into the cells as well as
other nutrients in the cell now what
happens when you have insulin resistance
okay you have one part of the body
that's not getting insulin
okay so there's a feedback loop that
comes around that causes your pancreas
to make massive amounts of insulin so
when you have instant resistance you
have a combination between insulin
deficiency and a massive spike in
insulin in certain other parts of the
body the massive spike of insulin causes
stuff like fatty liver and obesity but
the deficiency of insulin also creates
problems especially in your brain
because insulin believe it or not is an
anti inflammatory hormone so when you
have insulin resistance you have now you
have certain parts of your body that
don't get enough insulin you start
getting inflammation so a lot of the
inflammation that occurs with this is
really occurring because of a deficiency
of insulin in certain parts of your body
I mean let's just take the brain for
example when you have Alzheimer's and
Parkinson's there's something very
unique about these two right here in
your nerve cells you will see a severe
deficiency of glucose in the cell why
because there's not enough insulin
because of insulin resistance to allow
fuel to go into the nerve cells okay and
they die and so one of the treatments
for Alzheimer's is an insulin nasal
spray which sprays insulin right up
through your sinuses into the brain and
it shows some good results with dementia
the problem is eventually it keeps
creating more insulin resistance because
this is caused by a continuous exposure
to insulin okay now there's another
treatment for arrhythmias involving
giving a patient insulin into the heart
because it can increase the electrical
activity and increase the mobilization
of electrolytes why because insulin is
involved in the absorption of
electrolytes so you can see some of
these treatments are
designed to bypass what's really
happening insulin resistance alright so
I want to come back to this book for a
second and just touch on one thing if
you look at this section where they're
talking about the cause of insulin
resistance there's one area that I
highly disagree with and I'll tell you
why because it talks about eating
saturated fats will cause insulin
resistance okay and this is something
you'll see in the news oh yeah well it's
that sort of faster you're gonna get
diabetes etc etc so I pulled a string
and found the study that they're using
to base this information on of course it
was a a rodent study okay and as I try
to find the study you it's not readily
available you have to buy it it's forty
seven dollars for the study okay but you
can rent it for seven dollars which I
did and I'll show you right here it's
called high fat diet induced insulin
resistance lessons and implications from
animal studies okay and lo and behold if
you see what they fed the mice it was a
high-fat diet if you then look up what
that high fat diet consists of it's not
just a high-fat diet it's a high fat
plus high carbohydrate diet and we
already know if you combine high carbs
with eye fat you get a massive increase
of insulin so that fact basically
invalidates this study completely making
this data incorrect the truth is that
saturated fats have a very low effect on
insulin what has a massive effect is the
carbohydrates and that brings me back to
the biggest secret of the keto universe
and that is this all these side effects
from insulin resistance are treated with
separate medications as if they're their
own disease not being caused by
something and to put the icing in the
cake the diet recommended to resolve
these conditions are a high carbohydrate
diet the exact thing that causes in the
first place so what is the significance
of that data well it tells us the
importance of keto and in a minute
fasting is way more than we thought
because it directly targets this one
condition right here which indirectly
can help you
with all of these thanks for watching
hey guys real quick I have a new healthy
keto eating plan for you just go to dr.
Berg comm it's right on the front page I
put a link down below download it it's
free check it out